[Musique]
m
vous savez ce que je déteste sur les
américaines
tout en fait
surtout la comoé
vous êtes américains mais new york
vous autres flics faire du bruit comment
vous savez que je suis flic
vous n'avez pas l'air d'un avocat
tu fabriques et 7 007 de plaine fenioux
jazzer savate et en sécurité là
[Musique]
tu as été mon cul
ce qui fait une menace
héroïsme
figure rhénium militaire
nucléaire
il faut quelqu'un arrête c'est très bien
office tactique
c'est quoi un flingue de pirate c'est la
vieille école mais comme toi
non c'est j'imagine que vous avez
l'habitude l'encouragé pas mon fiston
mais moins on va vous exploser
ouais
oui
m
un peu
[Musique]
c'est toi qui cherche les ennuis ou ce
qu'ils trouvent c'est une question se
pose encore figure toi
[Musique]